[Music]
foreign
it's a little over 150 with all the
interviews the special series but anyway
for the purpose of our our naming
convention it is 100
the pill pod so today Victor and Eric
and I will be celebrating along with
some of the other voices you've heard a
few times up till now
litvik was supposed to be here today he
was almost here today but he became
suddenly indisposed and he asked to not
he asked me not to tell you why but I'm
going to tell you uh he had he had a
little bit of a he had a little bit of a
psychotic break because one of his
students submitted
uh what he described as a pornographic
midterm paper about all the angels in
Milton's Paradise Lost having sex with
each other and he couldn't handle it
you could share it I mean that would
have been such a good thing to talk
about on the podcast I mean that's just
read it out at this point
I I just would love to see Victor's face
like how he would respond to the student
like uh if that's even true
then I'd probably be disappointed I'd be
like look this is all really a generic
sex I don't even believe you've ever
been to a bad Sam conference or
something like that like you gotta
[ __ ] up the ante I want to see like
trees sprouting dicks and you trying to
[ __ ] them or something like that before
I'm even moderate and Milton's Paradise
Lost
the original anime also so exactly oh my
God if you come up to me and you're like
I got a sick [ __ ] twisted mind bro I
better like William F barrows better run
for the hills after hears you talking
otherwise I just am not impressed Matt I
feel like the number of curse words and
like sexually explicit content like for
the entire time that you've been gone
you've already like more than quadrupled
what like me Eric and pills have said
combined since wait you become more
Bourgeois since I was gone isn't that
like the contrary thing that you would
expect you spec clean up our language we
never use contractions anymore I'm here
to that George batayu the whole thing up
or something
so litvik is not here but as you can
hear the void has been more than filled
and do not make a joke about that please
so don't worry about it you could have
said the Gap has been field that would
be so much better we've covered over the
Gap you can hear Diego is back again
definitely have some questions for him
also Chris Satur and Chris you've
actually never been on a pill pod I
found out because all the episodes that
we did they weren't technically pill
pods they were like micro doses yeah
micronosis back when we used to have
that name yeah I'm very happy I'm very
happy to be here so thanks for the
invite and as you can hear there's a a
dark shadow
covering the Horizon of someone who's
appeared today we cannot yet see its
form clearly
but it is a very loud Shadow and its mic
is not close enough to wait's face and
still manages to be loud despite that oh
yeah I mean I don't need things in my
face in order to really make a splash
you know that right
yeah no anyways was that sexual I I
don't know I just read it that way now
I'm sure Mike I'm pretty sure my like
you know nice guy Twitter spaces my my
whole shtick is gone now just fast just
because of Matt's you know first five
minutes
and it's and it's not just us who's in
here the room with us today we also let
me see if I can do this the CIA is here
of course oh I've they're always
listening
my comment is that I miss Matt because
uh pills Eric and Victor are agreeing
with each other way too much
Ah that's what we're afraid of like we
just gotta be pragmatic you know it
could be became a pragmatist podcast
that was like yes Mission from day one
was to have disputes not to be all
Kumbaya with this [ __ ] I guess I am
more agreeable than I realized but like
I really thought in that rich or Brody
episode like I was dunking a bunch on
like dumb radical politics in that in
that episode but I feel like people
didn't maybe people didn't pick up on it
I don't know pills you didn't tell me if
any feedback that came back from that
episode ah you can check the YouTube
channel but that's okay first things
first there is a big news item that I
think we got it cover this is a full I
guess not full if you include all the uh
Islands but pretty much a full North
American podcast today we have Mexico
the United United States and Canada all
represented
and Armenia and armina
also in North America
anyway I'd like to start off uh if we
could just ask Diego what's your take
what's your take on the pink
and that was not sexual I meant the pink
wave now also not sexual
you mean uh you mean Lula in Brazil yes
well complicated man I mean we still
have roadblocks out of people that are
just not accepting the the result of the
election still a mess
um I think to be honest with you this is
this is more than nothing a victory for
the right not not as much as a victory
for the left as people will normally see
because you still can go to the number
of uh de putados and senadores like the
people that are actually working the
chamber in the two other powers beyond
the executive power and most of them are
from the same party as bolsonaro so this
represents a major rise of these uh
neo-conservative ideology in in Latin
America and the way I see it is that the
same way as lulab represents uh failed
attempt as at revolutionary politics
just as much as Byron represents a fail
at Temple revolutionary politics in in
North America I think as much as Biden
is not going to be able to change the
life and change the material conditions
of workers and improve the the quality
of life of people much of what brought
Trump to power on the first turn is
going to bring bolsonaro back to Power
again in Brazil That's my reading as as
you know this is a is a very like a
traditional reading from from leftist
politics in Latin America is that um
when the left provides a revolutionary
project and under delivers they are just
foreshadowing the return of a even more
reactionary right right-wing movement
after them so I think I think that's
that's that's what I can say the the
other two compliments I will give to
Lula is that after prison he was a
really changed man and this is not a
Will Ferrell joke that prison changed
him but it did it feels like he came out
with with more
um absolute Concepts like sovereignty uh
building a nation project which is nice
I I'm I like that type of of discourse I
don't know if it's going to be actually
be implemented at all but what scares me
is that I'm seeing in Lula the same type
of uh Speech patterns I'm seeing in
Petro in Colombia and boric in Chile
which is about bringing uh these Global
entities like otan and NATO and Ono and
Yuan to take care of the Amazon and
that's really really dangerous for us
um the way I see it is that the the
Latin American geopolitical Bloc needs
to find a sense of unity and defend
lithium and raw material serials instead
of bending over to to Global interests
and even like beyond the conspirinoid
point of view of this reading that's
what scares me like uh the fact that the
north the north is applauding the
victory of Lula makes me really really
scared I mean I agree with everything
that you said but you forgot about the
most important thing that this election
was about which is all the shot in Freud
I got to enjoy when I saw the
bolsonaries just crying that was what
this is all building too they were
sitting there praying to their God and
asking him to save the country from the
evil Communists and God responded and
said [ __ ] y'all and it's exactly what I
wanted to hear it was exactly the tears
that I want to see flow so I agree with
everything but we should let us take a
moment just you know my family the pain
of the fascists my family was really
confused because I have a bunch of
family members that are like right-wing
reactionaries really ignorant and I'm
like oh my God [ __ ] it like this is so
bad Lula won and like what like Diego
you're supposed to be a communist and I
yeah like yes exactly like what are you
guys thinking like no we're gonna become
a company's country now like you guys
you wish look of course not like this is
gonna go so much worse to my man you
think
it's the same way I feel here whenever
one of my students are like Biden is
going to bring communism to the United
States so I'm like God I wish that was
true yeah oh my God I sit there and
every day I wish that was the case but
you know I'm just so pessimistic that
it's uh
yeah is that is the reason for that uh
Diego because of just the the
institutions don't so like because uh
just because he won the presidency is
the presidential system similar to the
United States where like you need the
house and the Senate to do anything or
is it how does it work so like winning
presidency kind of doesn't actually give
you any legislative ability to pass
meaningful stuff or is is the problem
something else no the Pro the problem is
the three powers
right Judiciary legislative and
executive like the three branches of
Power are always like uh fighting and
negotiating as much as you guys but the
difference is that you have two parties
you have like 40.
right well we have three
oh yes technically technically yeah
yeah Matt only has two yeah that's true
yeah you have center right and right so
what would have been a better outcome
for the election or was this still the
best possible outcome this is the best
we can expect out of democracies in
Latin America I think I think yeah this
is like we have grown used to this chat
show and like there's there's not much
we can Aspire beyond that I mean we can
Aspire China to take over that'd be
awesome but
that's some that's that's a [ __ ] hot
take right there
I'm gonna leave it on that hot tape
of course Chris detour has uh muted
himself because I guess shelling doesn't
have an opinion on Democracy in Brazil
oh boy you're gonna get me into trouble
for this nope okay we are gonna move on
to our first other question which is
from a young man
known as uh lerpa derp
hey there pills this is leper dip
speaking hey congratulations on the
100th episode thank you you guys have
been truly life-changing and I'm forever
grateful for this amazing platform uh my
question for you guys is a two-parter
one is who is everyone's favorite
philosopher and why and then secondly
who is the most influential philosopher
in your life and why once again
congratulations
thank you lerpa derp now how are we
gonna do this go through one go around
at a time at a time I call I call
shelling
all right I'll start I'll start I'll say
my favorite philosopher is of course
Nietzsche because he didn't believe in
philosophy Asterix
with no sub note but the most important
philosopher in my life is Emmanuel Kant
because I spend my days forever thinking
God damn it I wish you weren't so right
but you know if philosophy is about
reason he pushed it as far as it could
get and we're just picking up the crumbs
still today
who's next I guess I could go
um for me I think my favorite would have
to be Marlo Ponte
um I would say my favorite and most
influential I was a tough it was tough
to pick between marilopanti and Lacon in
terms of influencing the way that I
think about life
um those two probably changed my
perspective on like how I think about my
own ability to engage with the world in
a meaningful way to make a meaningful
difference or maybe more precisely the
ways in which I can't make a meaningful
difference or like the limits to how uh
I can engage with the world and like the
way that the world ends up seeming to me
um but then I guess I don't know that
like that's my answer for like most
influential and in a way favorite
but like I I just have to throw in also
that my probably my favorite political
philosopher is just the most basic of
basic Jon Stewart Mills because he just
puts the arguments in their most
succinct and I think persuasive way of
Defending kind of like philosophical
liberalism and the most interesting and
in the most egalitarian
way it's like so people you know people
who are anti-liberal will always want to
point to John Locke or uh as like the
the paradigmatic example but I think
they don't pay enough attention and Matt
of course will agree with me strongly on
this on the emancipatory potential in
Jon Stewart Mill oh I agree and on that
note well the answer for me is uh well
both answers really are Eric because I
mean where would my life be without him
you know it'd be a dark and demented and
sexless place and so really you know I
have to give credit where credit is due
um guilty as charged yeah uh but no the
serious answer I suppose uh for the
first one would be a person I'm going to
call Carl Rawls uh
or John Marks you can take whichever one
after them cheating slightly uh so the
nice thing about John Marks uh is again
the synthesis uh of interest between uh
Power and Justice uh and I think both of
these things are important and John
Marks uh or Carl Rawls really provides
us with the resources we need both to
theorize a uh account of Justice that's
appropriate for our society today and
interrogate the forms of power that
inhibit it being realized in terms of
the person personally who I probably
have gotten the most from
uh
I'd say it goes back and forth between
being Hannah Arendt uh or possibly
starring character guard
um you know I read both of them when I
was really young uh Canon rents kind of
account of evil and the reason people do
bad things really impacted me
emotionally and Sarah and Kierkegaard
was somebody I just read so much when I
was in my early 20s that it actually was
hard for me sometimes to disconnect my
way of thinking and feeling about things
from what I read in his books just
because I kind of got lost in them so
much all right let's go to Diego next
this is a complicated thing to respond
to I don't know I think at the moment my
mind is at um Spinoza but like a radical
delusion reading of Spinoza like I
really like this um notion of monistic
materialism and uh most influential I
think would be zizik probably Zizek took
me uh really made me interested he just
added on zizak took you and that would
be more interesting than anything oh
yeah he will prepare it as that as well
yeah I think the fact that uh I don't
know why he he's he was inflation in his
form
not as much in his writing because I
think his books are rather repetitive
after the eighth one but um but he's but
his form his form is really something
like the fact that he can make a
philosophy so interesting and so comical
is just it's just so cool
yeah I remember I read um uh sex on the
failed absolute and I was like oh this
is more or less the same thing as you
said yeah less than I think which is
more or less the same as The Parallax to
you which is more or less the same as uh
you know Supply logic yeah let's kind of
innovate a little bit I kind of almost
see him as like a beatnik you know how
like Jack Kerouac wrote you know these
continuous stories uh on the road it's
just one giant book where he kind of
adds new flavors to it by the way self
self self uh name dropping my new book
is about to come out next month oh man
that was on Earth all right okay any
chance of an English English translation
no not I don't plan to do an English
translation it was a complicated enough
to write let's see let's see how it goes
if it goes well I'll probably translate
it
congrats Link's in the description for
sure I'm gonna do a one of those all
right since weeks we got it we gotta
work our way up to the Chris answer to
this but so why don't we uh Eric pen
ultimate it'll be Eric I did also want
to say though congratulate Chris uh also
had a new piece that came out recently
and what was the magazine
magazine yeah so congratulations
cosmogony
yeah is it my turn to speak or oh we're
saving the best I'll uh I'll go through
mine because mine will be quick
um I think in terms of like influential
or formative influence on me I think
it's definitely like an even split
between Walter Benjamin and Bruno LaTour
I thought a lot about material culture I
I got turned I got turned by them again
I was taken wait our love isn't
reciprocal that's so painful to me
oh no love is reciprocal Matt I know I
gotta ask Victor about like I'm I gotta
remember these running jokes now yes
Matthew McManus Matthew McManus is in
love with the image of Eric and opening
me up I don't want to know what he does
to your image in the dark recesses of uh
his home his private I didn't even
remember because it's that violent so I
couldn't even tell you yeah I mean you
like you like berserk so I can imagine
you're a sexual deviant he opened me
thank you mind soul and most importantly
body
um so it's an even split you could say
between Matt Walter Benjamin and LaTour
I think favorite right now is probably
Charles Sanders purse hence hence my uh
well I'm focusing on him right now and
hence the last episode with with rorty
and me being a little more sympathetic
towards pragmatism than I usually am
it's he's still got some work to do but
I I liked Rawls but yeah Charles Sanders
current favorite current I really like
the last episode actually and yeah I was
a bit surprised that it wasn't more
heated uh since I expected at least one
person was going to come with the hammer
uh towards Brody but yeah I gotta drill
down into his nominalism because I think
it's just another kind of idealism we
should have we should have I think he's
very expressive about that I mean he
says that heigo was the most influential
figure on his work which a lot of people
are surprised by no he is he he TR he
takes it he reps it yeah I don't like it
but I like him for taking the position
it's good yeah that's me that's me let's
do uh Chris well um I think well
everyone knows my my favorite
philosopher is fwj shelling and I want
to just take this time to uh respond to
a question that pills asked me
um in the oldest systematic program of
German idealism both herderlin Hegel and
shelling
um have an absolute deconstruction of
the state and they say that the state
itself is too mechanical and that it
itself cannot be an idea so the state
needs to be in a sense demolished and so
I would say that is a politic that I
that I my back and that I think both
shelling and holderling and even novalis
would back so I've been reading a lot of
novellas and shelling and FH Bradley I
think shelling and novales are probably
my two favorite thinkers at the moment
and the reason why is because you know I
adhere to a kind of shilingian
naturalism where I think that one of our
biggest problems is that we can't get
past the subject object binary that we
tend to objectify both people races
identities and nature
and so I think a lot of the problem with
the climate crisis is how we view nature
and I think the schillingian project is
um a great way of remodel modernizing
um German idealism and the approach to
reach back to German idealism and to
rethink these Concepts because
um you know the encyclopedic project of
Hegel and novalis and Evan shelling's
late project this kind of ontological
existentialism is a movement back to you
know finding the alpha in the Omega as
freedom not some kind of religious
totality but that's me so is that kind
of my first suggestion wait is your
influential and favorite the same
um no I shaped your thinking the most
um well I always say that you're worse
I'm gonna have to agree with pills it
was Kant it was that moment when I heard
sapere Uday no dare to know have the
courage to use your own understanding
that phrase
challenging me to the point where like I
stayed after an hour after a lecture and
I just sat there going what the hell
does it mean to dare to know have the
courage to think for yourself I mean for
you know a 21 22 to 24 year old thinking
about you know Having the courage to
think for yourself
um that's a that's an idea that kind of
shook me we just we just called them 20
year olds here I also think like I I get
a lot of heat for beating up onto those
but I think you know delis was a big
part of my life for like six years I
think all of you know that so I think I
have to bring I have to I have to give
some although I don't disagree although
I don't agree with this project anymore
I do think he's still influential but I
would say definitely shelling and can't
actually probably I'm not sure if you
remember this but the moment where you
and I started talking in a friendly way
and not in an antagonistic way uh was a
night where I had smoked a very very big
joint and I was watching uh I think it
was a Superman cartoon and it was two
o'clock in the morning and you started
sending me I also had a few drinks uh
these messages about Duluth get the
catalog out there you're so angry and
you were like I don't understand and I
just started spewing language at you
from thousand plateaus which made more
sense to me when I was big and drunk
than it did prior and you actually sent
me a message back being like wow man you
know so much about the Liz I have to say
I'm somewhat impressed and then you were
like do you want to come meet us
afterwards and that was do you do you
realize you just summed up the problem
with delicians and that exact thing that
they just you know just
the actual reason that Chris stopped
liking Duluth was because he heard a
talk of Rosie Bray Dottie oh my God yes
I can relate it was really popular on
that subreddit oh yeah yeah
intersectionality so bad no but it
wasn't her it wasn't her her feminism or
her critique um you know with Donna
haraway it was how she like labeled
Duluth as this like staunch materialist
and and how he was rooted in in Spinoza
and she she didn't talk about the
bergsonian and the Marxist and the and
the Hume aspect it was just like beating
Spinoza over the head I mean like I
agree late 90s I'm sorry late 20th
century critical theory was basically
beating Spinoza over the head as hard as
it could go well and I mean I approve of
this because it produced a lot of
interesting stuff but let's just be
clear about what happened but then we go
around really fast saying our worst and
most hated philosopher just for the fun
of it yeah I like that oh can I start oh
my God yes and RAM I'll take I'll take
on RAM for sure well that's such a neat
that's using philosopher as a really
Evolution yeah that's not even a real
philosopher Jordan Peterson
[Laughter]
yeah I just wanted to share another
objectivism I think is is necessary is
is it's a Pity but it's necessary but
has pills even answered the first
question yet because I feel like he
hasn't yeah I said he started
okay most influential Nietzsche would
most prefer to read if I was like
trapped in a room so [ __ ] on one guys go
ahead yeah I've got it's hard for me I
gotta think for a second can we just all
can we just take one meta moment and
just say the right and they're in a pre
appropriation of Strauss right now if I
hear strauss's name one more time I
think I'll slit my wrist and watch the
blood drip down my arm like honestly I'm
so over hearing stress online somebody's
gonna be violating the natural
laws is bad but stress isn't as bad as
people oh
is not that bad I agree it's drowsy
tanks are bad
I'd say Bertrand Russell
not because he was really bad at writing
just because he was the most smug
[ __ ] when it came to what philosophy
is and what it does yeah I I could say
that there is a philosopher that I don't
know that I just want to hate everything
I hear about him makes me want to hate
him and that's Deliz
every time I hear like delusions like it
just sounds like I don't know there's
there's a certain kind of move
um that I see in in this kind of
philosophizing that like I see again
unfairly uh biased unfair of just kind
of like this fetishization of like
novelty and and change and just like I'm
like and like creativity and just like
all this stuff I'm just like this is
just this is this is this is stupid no
you don't like anything I hear about it
you were reading heart and negri on the
list okay yeah so heart [ __ ] that's my
answer thank you very much so heart and
I agree
that's a Giza upload isn't it yeah
that's not that's not true I'm speaking
speaking of de los and Zizek the Liz
always said I can't write by myself I
need to be writing by reading or writing
by reading someone else Zizek is the
same except that person is himself he
just needs to read his own books and
then rewrite them yeah but but we cut
him a break because of his method of
survival like he has admitted many times
that finishing his books is just an
excuse not to himself so
can we can we also agree I mean he's
also got another model wife he's got to
get to this is going to be really that's
King [ __ ] King [ __ ] this is going to be
really controversial but I'm gonna say
Hegel oh my god well I can't I can't
stand Hegel you better walk around with
a [ __ ] bulletproof vest is it Hegel
or the hegelians exactly aliens
I'm Pippin Pippin Hig aliens you know
Terry Pinkard you know follows a Pinker
but I do like Holgate and I think HS
Harris is great anyways I better also
start wearing it you better also start
bringing an umbrella every time you go
to a conference because like every
delusion is going to jerk off on you now
like the minute you arrive just because
you said I mean I'm wondering
State philosopher we have that in
Congress I'm wondering is there a
distinction too between the philosopher
that we like hate the most because like
versus some because there's a lot of
philosophers that I just like disagree
with a lot about a lot that they say but
I really enjoy reading them yeah and I
really like like I think Nietzsche for
me is like a pretty good example of a
philosopher that I thought like in some
ways I disagree with a lot of his
conclusions but I really enjoy reading
him yeah um I think that's true even if
some more like conservative I think
that's kind of true of Strauss too like
I I like I don't like a lot of this
stuff but I think he's he can it's like
the philosopher you love to hate
if you take his argument separate from
his actual writing then it gets very
annoying I haven't been showed on that I
prefer the neoplating and silver Plato
like I prefer reading platinus and
proclusive oh wait I didn't hear Matt's
least favorite philosopher yet generics
yeah oh the answer is very simple it's
Alexander Dugan I had to read a huge
amount oh my God I had to read a huge
amount of his books and material answer
a review uh that um who's coming out of
Commonwealth soon and
it was one of those rare occasions
because I agree with Victor like they're
a conservative and even far-right
authors who I detest their politics but
I will admit they're good writers like
Schmidt is a beautiful writer very clear
very rememberable uh and there are
authors who I really tend to agree with
but I detest their writing style so this
is a good example right Mike Hogan was
like yeah
Dugan was reading somebody where I was
like this writing style is just a
[ __ ] War crime and because the fact
that it's endorsing war crimes makes it
even worse like this should just be
thrown into a toilet and burned with
unrelenting Mercy because at the end of
like several weeks going through it I
seriously started wondering to myself if
I gone into the wrong career and if I
just should have like stuck with
landscaping and become a whole
full-blown alcoholic because there would
have been some dignity to that as
opposed to reading this goddamn book I
don't know who was the one that said it
but somebody said something similar
about and Rand they said that and run
back and and ran books should not be
taken thrown away lightly they should be
thrown away with this like with the
spice yeah with great Forest land
I mean Atlas bad I mean don't get me
wrong at the shrug and The Fountainhead
are both bad books and if you read any
of our technical stuff it also deserves
oh yeah in the toilet seat of history
but like Dugan takes it to a whole new
level because at least Diane Ryan can be
clear uh and she has a couple of
memorable phrases Dugan is like if you
took a word salad of fascism and just
pumped it into every pretentious
person's head it's awful and well maybe
there is no Dugan maybe it's just an AI
that crawls fascism
I felt that way about about Nick land we
read a piece about from of Nick land for
the podcast and like he was that was you
know I kind of had similar feelings
where I was like the writing is so bad
and stupid and like the conclusions are
also like I mean in that particular
piece I thought it was great conclusions
the conclusions weren't that bad but it
was it was an extremely pretentious
piece of writing and and like
considering what he went on to uh argue
for I'm I'm not I'm not I know I agree
with that like it's once you do the work
and like we had to do all the work to
make Nick land interesting and then I
came away being like Oh that was some
cool stuff but when you first sort of
start reading it it's just like what the
[ __ ] is he talking about and then and
then you start to try to draw
connections with you have to do all of
the work and that kind of [ __ ]
this is like I can accept people being
pretentious or egotistical in their
writing like when Nietzsche writes I am
a Destiny and Wars will be fought in my
name I'm like that's pretty highfalutin
stuff man but like I write such good
books yeah but I'm like your niches why
am I trying to get away with it when I
read somebody who's a [ __ ] hack who's
unpleasant to read and they're like I am
the [ __ ] man it's almost like dealing
with that drunk guy at the bar who comes
and sits next to you is talking about
what a big shitty is even though nobody
wants to be around him and you're just
like would you not shut the [ __ ] up and
leave me alone like that's the way
dealing with like the Iran's and the
dugans of the world it should well that
sounds like what every woman's response
to Nietzsche actually was
IRL exactly actually I don't know if you
guys are aware of these but there's a
currently ongoing conversation infinite
conversation between zizik and Herzog
created by an AI machine learning
program oh Werner Herzog yeah yeah you
can you can go online and there's an
infinite conversation between Zizek and
Herzog just like how empty is the
universe I'm into that yeah machine
generated yeah it's machine generated
it's absolutely hilarious I was
listening to you in the morning during
the shower and a couple of points make
sense and I was like my God what the
[ __ ] is language
library of Babel yeah this has to be the
first time in history that someone
listened to an AI conversation between
two philosophers in the shower you're
good to know good to know yeah it was so
interesting I wasn't like trying to make
sense but but you know like you you are
fooled by it you definitely believe
they're having this conversation because
the AI is it's not too bad it's not too
bad well what does her talk say it's
like the universe is nothing and Jesus
looks like no no it's less than nothing
in her dog it's like no there's a
nothingness that's lesser than even less
than nothing no it's it's interesting
like they're they're discussing uh
there's a link they're having
conversations about uh nature culture
yeah you can play a little bit on the on
the it's actually for free and it's open
I love them in the mandalorians yeah
let's let's listen to them a little bit
there is this inner distance a
Detachment
you say to yourself This is not me it
was some kind of Stacker I have this
horrible fantasy not a nightmare but
almost a happy fantasy where I would
like to know how a serial killer key
I would never kill any man and two
cavity too much of a coward and the
moment when I look down I'm already
distancing myself from it
I think you're right but I have a
similar fantasy which I've never spoken
about if someone would lock me in the
room and they were revolver in there and
five naked women who were completely
Shameless
and close the door and I would know that
he would come back in one hour I don't
know what would happen to me what about
that her job that was incredible yeah
yeah those were similar topics yeah I
was listening for like 15 minutes it was
amazing it was really really amazing oh
my God that's uh insight into Diego's
hardest fap of my life
okay Eric worst philosopher did you
answer this yet worst philosopher sorry
I'm just still picturing Diego cleaning
the shower after that
well he's gotta he's gotta rebuild the
the tile work after that remember when a
listener told us that our humor was
getting a bit too male and too like
adolescent I feel like this episode's
gonna be six white males talking about
philosophy come on yeah we're Beyond
criticism
males talking about philosophy is just
philosophy yeah exactly
Asterix yeah I I you know I'm
wishy-washy on these points right but
okay
my philosophers that I love to hate
let's say starting with Descartes not a
big fan of his conclusions
but he opens up the problems that are
just that have just driven Philosophy
for so long and I love him for that okay
next one probably more more relevant to
what I'm working on is Ferdinand to so
sir and just
all the philosophy of the 20th century
that the signifier signified [ __ ]
runs through that gets me right I do not
like the side of lacan that takes up so
sir I don't like that debate they all
have about Fraga and the zero point bad
year jumps in there at some point I'm
not a big fan of any of that
you wouldn't even have access to the
question if it weren't for for so sir
don't you think or is that there it's
the same answer yeah I I love the fact
that he opened up
the conversation about signifiers being
I'm not we've gone into that before I
say that's that's my philosopher I love
to hate would be probably somewhere
between Descartes on the metaphysical
side and so sir
on the uh at least what like people have
picked them up on the structuralism and
the the sociological applications of his
work have been can we all agree can we
all agree on angles as well too Marx was
a great writer by himself but angles is
dialectics of Nature and his
anti-shelling piece is terrible
a western Marxist angles is all right
okay we're moving on to a new question
I'm sorry to be the cop you know it's my
least favorite job but next question is
about art from Nicolas hi guys I wanted
to say first of all that I was a
conservative Peterson I only two and a
half years ago and zizak alongside the
George Floyd protests pulled me out of
that uh which led me to your Zizek video
which led me to your podcast so
um thanks for doing this and making it
accessible to people like me who don't
have a background in theory
um this isn't a theory question but uh I
am a painter and I'm curious what
everyone's favorite piece of art is so
happy 100th episode
hey thanks
we change the Peterson bro's life I feel
that feels good man yeah that that makes
everything worth it yeah Diego you
probably hear that all the time from
the equivalent well yeah I I I without
any intention I position myself as a
gateway drug out of um
Peterson Bros and is there a Mexican
Peterson
well there's a bunch it's it's it's a
[ __ ] pandemic man worldwide I think
all this this coaching mentality and all
these guys that um uh transform idealism
into us into a sense of meritocracy and
they transform everyone into those days
of job you know you know these
theological metaphor of job no job was
the one that had to endure all the
tortures and and have his faith be the
survival of everything and then his
faith was the proof of uh of theology in
itself um I think everyone now is just
like um in the Theology of meritocracy
in the sense that everybody has to
believe in if they don't even if they
don't really believe they just feel that
they have to suffer to the struggle in
order to be deserving of that place so
in that sense yes the world is full of
Jordan Peterson's like these bastards
[ __ ] that are selling cheap ideas
under the notion of you have to pull
yourself up by your bootstraps and the
sense of like positive freedom and all
this stupidity well there are rooms that
need cleaned everywhere right yeah well
he's he's he's the one that should start
cleaning his own room to begin with
dirty rooms are are something that
transcends all times you know yeah going
back to the Greeks dirty rooms the
dragons the dragons of chaos his
daughter yeah dirty palaces anyway does
anyone have a favorite uh artist I know
Chris does and I also artwork yeah uh I
can't do a work because I have to be
visual yeah that was my same question
because I was going to say Moonlight
Sonata third movement
maybe we could maybe we could specify
does anyone have a favorite painting I I
feel like I feel like Chris has
something uh on that yeah yeah my my
favorite actually I'm a huge fan of
Scandinavian art so like Edward monk um
Eugene Johnson
um hammer show is my favorite painter
and his and his uh yeah and his painting
interior with four etchings which is a
beautiful piece it's his wife facing um
in back of us and there's a beautiful
desk and a chair and some image oh my
God I can't even say it some pic some
paintings on the on the wall there with
some very cool kind of Scandinavian
colors so he's a beautiful artist and he
really knows how to paint the
consciousness of light and lines and the
way Shadows reflect on specific objects
it's beautiful I have a I have a
gorgeous picture of you in front of a
hammer shoy when they came to Toronto I
think we were looking at that after the
Turner exhibit or something then we went
across the street and got drunk it was a
good day so just in case you don't have
an artwork I think uh music film
whatever it is that'll apply but for me
it is a painting in at least a painting
period and mine is cubism before Picasso
made it all like field painting and flat
so the early cubists they tried to paint
a room or a scene from
like 25 angles at the same time it's
Picasso and Brock at the beginning and
then when they started doing other stuff
there's a group of artists in Paris
called sexyando
and I think they that's my favorite bit
because they would paint a room from
multiple perspectives and before it
turns into the Picasso that everybody
knows and goes you know my kid could do
that but the back story that I find
really interesting here is they were
being influenced by so many different
things they were influenced by
photography was becoming popular so you
could take like 20 photos of a room
print them out and then paint the same
room from 20 different angles uh that
was big they were looking at art from
other cultures for the first time in the
history of European art at least saying
are looking at African art for example
and trying to incorporate that and also
uh quantum physics so this was right at
the time quantum physics was becoming a
thing you've got the wave particle
duality and all this messed up stuff at
a subatomic level and they were trying
to reflect on this through ART and we
eventually see Picasso get very lazy by
the end of of his career but before he
was lazy when he was trying to deal with
all this in an artistic sense the early
cubists uh cubism pre 1918 is what I'm
going to say was my favorite
I like a AI generated art
like uh the Google Deep Web stuff no
I'll say I this actually is like a
different I haven't talked about this
aspect of myself I think I have a little
bit but I used to be really into
Renaissance art so I super loved
following the trajectory from late
medieval art into the Renaissance
and that whole Confluence of of
Architects and mathematicians and
artists in Florence and Italy you know
like Brunelleschi teaching one point
perspective to the artists and then that
becoming a defining feature of like kind
of Renaissance realism and then I looked
around and I realized oh my God the
northern Renaissance is actually also
really appealing like hiranhas Bosh's
paintings are just so [ __ ] crazy
and maybe that's not a not the most
exciting answer but that's where my
head's at like I was so close to just
just wanting to become like a
Renaissance art scholar art and
architecture crazy but yeah I'd put my
I'd throw my ball into like the the
Renaissance Italy I I want to like run
Southern Renaissance better but I think
the northern Renaissance painters are
also pretty key
the Dutch yeah the Dutch run I don't
know something about those black and
white floors is just so nice it's like a
checkerboard it just it just gets me off
you know I don't know I don't know what
it is I love seeing little scientific
instruments in the background I'm like
[ __ ] yeah we're getting smarter I don't
know I just love it no it's as soon as
Matt shows up again then Erica no longer
represses sexuality
something's happening I guess running
out of virility in the show that the
rest of you can attain by yourself
all right something I love astrolabes
um
I'm pretty artistically like like
uneducated and unknowledgeable
um but I suppose you know I I suppose if
I had to pick something maybe I I had
like a brief interest in kind of like
French impressionism
um as a consequence of taking philosophy
of art classes and also it's linked to
marilopanti and I think often uh
impressionism is used uh to sort of talk
about like the way perception appears
and like that French impressionism
somehow captures something about our
perception that the way that it actually
functions which is like that it doesn't
actually pick up on like these
fine-grained details the Perfection but
it captures this like overall image that
it's like extremely familiar on like the
way that light is perceived and all
these different things I think
impressionism does a nice job of kind of
like capturing that which I really
appreciate but I have to also agree with
uh Eric too that I I really find some
Renaissance art exciting just like it's
in it like the crowd images of the of
like you know these perfectly like
sculpted people and like uh you know
even thinking about I have on my wall
actually the uh you know the School of
Athens which I think is I think that's
Renaissance art right that's like
Italian Renaissance it's like Raphael
Raphael yeah that's right Ponte just in
case anyone wants to look it up he
writes at length on Cezanne yes and says
on this to the light and it's almost
like fuzzy light it kind of describe it
yeah yeah there's something about
there's something about the effect of
religion and and religiosity that gets
into their artwork like I'm not very
religious but just seeing the
inspiration that that creates and the
painting and the architecture and the
altars and the frescoes like it just
gets me I don't know what it is like I'm
not religious I don't I don't care but
just something about that that in
inspiration in that
fundamental yearning for something just
it just gets me and no I agreement
artistically and it's amazing the thing
for me though is more what I find it
like fun about some of those things like
the School of Athens is a good example
but I think there's lots of compositions
like this where there's just so much
action going on and like you if you look
at the painting or you look at the
Fresco more you just see like all the
characters doing all these different
things and like that makes it just like
a fun experience to look at and be like
like I'm looking at the School of Athens
right there's like some guy in the
corner and he's like scribbling in a
notebook and like and there's like some
weird interactions there's some weird
interactions happening between people
like in the corners of the of the
composition and it's just like that
makes it like a really interesting like
thing to to look at so I'm just going to
say the great thing about that painting
the School of Athens is hypatia
hypatious in it actually yeah yeah my
brother my brother had his houses in the
back of his office as well you know your
description Victor remind me of a book
by Freud uh telling the story of
Leonardo da Vinci I don't know if you
guys have read it
right exactly super interesting he goes
into the letters that da Vinci left and
makes a psychoanalytical uh reading of
of that post mode post mortem Da Vinci
his relation to Fresco versus oil
paintings is super super interesting
highly recommended I don't remember the
name of the book I'm gonna I'm gonna try
to find it I'll link it to you guys
later
I'm just gonna be a smug [ __ ] for the
sake of it and saying that liking
Raphael is like liking Avengers end game
there's so much action yes I agree I
agree look
um
you are a [ __ ] snob though that's
okay but like I will say you know it's
uh yeah of course I don't like I don't
happen to like superhero movies but
there are definitely equivalent things
that uh that I do enjoy that are
similarly low brow but yeah [ __ ] you uh
it's what was the name
it's fun to look at what was the name of
this musician that adorno really loved
when in the in the book that he sheds on
Jazz he talks about tone Shredder this
is a shredder shredders
Schoenberg Schoenberg exactly Schomberg
oh my God that's that's for me that if
if you say Schaumburg you are a
bourgeoisie there's there's no Escape in
it yeah like I'm gonna take you to the
guillotine holding hands but the
dissonance and the totality man come on
I don't know about the 12 tone music I
think I don't know is pretty
Bourgeois like having a helicopter land
in the middle of your Orchestra just so
you can get the sound real quick look at
that recorded sound drinking drinking
tears from African kids yeah
all right I like Raphael though I think
the mannerist stuff is is really really
good yeah well I think we have not yet
heard from uh Matthew and what what are
the chats about the 80s movie or an 80s
American Rock Anthem you know oh yeah I
mean they all go together I mean the
movie is Purple Rain the soundtrack is
purple rain and the artist of course is
Prince or sometimes the artist formerly
known as Prince
yeah that would work too no no uh my
favorite painting is uh the body of the
Dead Christ in the Tomb uh which is a
painting from the Renaissance period
um and it's widely considered to be the
first materialist interpretation of
religion and art and It produced
actually a lot of interesting commentary
from people like Dostoevsky and
christeva
um and also uh she's like later on right
with this idea of the profanation of the
Sacred uh and I also just think it's a
very moving uh image of its own accord
about the human condition in terms of
like my favorite novels
um
it's probably a
we haven't been doing that you don't
need to answer that novels
okay it's just like no one else said
that so I just said that's taking extra
he's answering extra questions teacher
it's not fair no but but Victor you like
La can why would you interrupt him he
wants to say something
that's going to be an intervention there
on this it's going to make them think
that would happen a long time ago but um
I guess you know I forget piece of art
so it'd either be Samuel Beckett's how
it is
um or possibly like um the road by Karma
McCarthy I also thought that was a
beautiful book
so there's between my two uh authors
nice uh I think we had to
um read that book I remember I took a
philosophy class on meaning of life and
that was like a book that we read
because it's like pretty nihilist isn't
it nihilistic isn't it or am I maybe I'm
mistaking it for something else well it
has a sequence in it where a child's
mother thinks about killing him because
the world is so bad right the father
convinces her not to and so her decision
is to kill herself uh in order to spare
him having to watch her die of
depression and then the kid and the
father walk on through the Wasteland and
that's the opening of the book so this
sounds like Patrick suskin's perfume
have you read that that's a morbid book
oh I've heard it's supposed to be good
yeah that's supposed to be really
reflection Twisted it's amazing yeah
nobody say Lord of the Rings because
that's mine beckon's how it is yeah
all right I'm gonna package the next two
questions together because one's not
really a question it's more of a a
statement about how
great we are awesome yeah always good to
hear but we're kind of Shifting most of
the other questions are about propaganda
and work so keep that in mind the first
one is from uh mapita
hi so
I was kind of lost in the sense that
much things around were turning space
let's say into a not very friendly
environment for me to have it
and really thanks to this project I was
able to provide a mental space that I
was lacking off
where I can figure out on how to get out
from the places of insane control over
me
so I think that's uh it's kind of like a
thank you so I I hope it could be a
criticism that I misinterpreted but why
yeah there's a space we make a space
where you can think outside of you know
the norms delightful uh and the second
one is related just a word of
encouragement from Switzerland because
even if it doesn't seem possible to cut
the Giant's head it might still be
possible to infect it
and that strand of imaginary symbolic
bug might yet accidentally emerge from
your circle in your political
intellectual frustrations
and in the meanwhile some of us are
definitely enjoying it so keep it up I
love you guys yeah that's nice that's a
bit of a David and Goliath medical
metaphor there I liked it yeah I like
that Swiss could be that uh ominous
sounding the only I was in this which I
was in the I was in the Geneva airport
for a bit and and the only thing I know
about Switzerland is my God it was like
a bottle of sparkling water for six
Swiss Francs and I was like outraged by
the price flying over flying over the
Alps was one of the greatest moments and
seeing those mountains up high was just
beautiful no snowboarding in the Alps is
pretty [ __ ] Kick-Ass too I went to
Switzerland and it's a beautiful country
uh with fairly stiff but otherwise
friendly people although I will admit I
went down the street and burned and
they're only like 10 Banks uh on either
side of me and I was kind of
disappointed because I was like
shouldn't this whole thing just be
[ __ ] Banks updating not enough banks
in Switzerland that's uh feedback coming
from Matthew McManus please they're all
digital now increase your Banks please
anyway what I wanted to what I wanted to
reflect on those questions because we
all do this to varying degrees uh
Diego's got his channel Matt has a real
job and uh Chris does a bunch of these
Twitter spaces but it's kind of what is
it what is it for when we're whining
about not actually being able to change
the world but still studying philosophy
and that sort of making a space that's
relatively entertaining while still
dealing with philosophy in a way that is
not the philosophy of the world which
tends to be very low pragmatic self-help
here's how to improve yourself type
philosophy rather than just being like
it's the world's fault that it's [ __ ]
up I didn't do this well zuzik likes to
point to an old holocaust joke that's
appropriate for my own experience uh
yeah I'm gonna go there whereas there
are these two Jews and they're sitting
there in the middle of the Holocaust and
they're reading Nazi newspapers and one
of them looks at the other and he's like
why are you doing that and he's like
well because when I read this we're in
control of all the banks all the major
corporations and we rule the world and
then go to the real world and what are
we doing we're about to be dragged to
the gas Chambers right uh and so there's
something similar applies where I go to
my day job and nothing much happens uh
you know I teach people uh but if I read
right wing media apparently I'm
transforming generations of students
into postmodern neo-marxists so that's
also one of the reasons I enjoy reading
conservative literature that's uh that's
funny I thought you were that that
holocaust joke starts just like gizek's
other Holocaust jokes I guess he has a
bunch right the one where uh jokes
plural right yeah the one where the one
where the two Jews are laughing uh
they're in heaven and you know he says
uh and you wouldn't get it yeah exactly
exactly and then God's like what are you
guys laughing at he's like oh we're
laughing about like that time he fell
over right before he got dragged into
the gas chamber and he's like guys he's
like that's just not that funny and then
he's like well you had to be there
to get it can I can I take a shot of the
answer please
um I was just rereading Society a
spectacle by gideborg and I like his
notion of even if we are trapped in the
spectacle and understanding the
spectacle not as the accumulation of
images but the fact that our social
relationships are mediated through
images and
um the job that we do in a way is to
remind people that there is something
real beyond the spectacle and um and
listening to these two guys that send
the messages is is something I I've
received many many similar messages
where people say yeah man like thank you
I got to question uh what was behind the
news behind the narrative like just and
not not even in a in a conspiracy theory
sense that oh my God like Beyond
propaganda there's a real world but you
know like in in a very simple sense like
reminding myself of I need to focus more
on my family and and take care of my
body and be aware of my health and go
outside and work out and eat healthy and
take care of my uh my appearances you
know like remind yourself that there's a
reality beyond the spectacle because I
do feel there's a there's a great price
to be paid especially by the younger
Generations uh being born into the
Society of spectacle my wife is a is a
practicing La Canyon psychoanalyst and
after the pandemic the number of
patients she has has multiplied like by
crazy amounts she has been uh like doing
at home interventions because of a
suicide attempt and she has like I had
to leave the house at 11 PM to save
people that just swallow a lot of pills
and I I feel like the mental pain that
uh late capitalism is producing is is a
real problem and we're just seeing the
the the the the the paints then the the
Grievances and uh
the Deep wounds that this is just
starting to show up and I think the work
we do even if you know philosophy has
this certain therapeutical aspect of it
as Maurice per luponti will say like uh
start on your own body uh you reconnect
with the real world you see that there's
something beyond the spectacle and in
that sense like listening to these two
audios I think you guys should also
upload yourselves because it's part of
your work it's it's part of what you
produce on these people that you remind
them that there's a reality Beyond
propaganda noise [ __ ] jokes and and
paranoia Chris was bringing up
neoplatonism earlier because what you
just said sounds really uh really
Gnostic neoplatonism Gnostic we're
trapped in the world and our world of
images but there's a Sophia outside of
the world Chris I should mention I don't
know if our viewers are aware he's an
active Twitter user and does spaces
where he hosts philosophy discussions so
I wanted to know Chris have you gotten a
few feedback like this and what makes
you do it well
um partly because my my friends run like
probably one of the best podcasts so I
couldn't I couldn't even compete with
that and I was joking um
I need to go to Twitter and find out the
[ __ ] that people are saying about me I I
actually really wanted
um to hear I wanted discussion that's
what I wanted but I wanted discussion
where we could load like level the
playing field so we could bring in you
know we would bring in specific
academics to talk about a text or talk
about ideas and then you know for 30
minutes be engaged with the person and
then 30 minutes we talk to the actual
people and I thought that this this was
kind of a healthy way of talking to you
know diverse people from all over the
world and most of the people that we we
talked to were all from Europe we had
people from South America
a lot all over Australia as well too so
it was good to hear you know that we
were affecting change specific change on
Twitter because I'll tell you Twitter
spaces are actually kind of sad they're
either nfts or they're right-wing people
you know yelling about Biden for the
next like 10 years so we were getting a
lot of messages like thank you so much
this is fantastic that we can tune in
and learn about you know Edith Stein who
not a lot of people read or Whitehead
that you know people want to read and
you know get into process of reality and
they don't have the means or sometimes
they don't they're not they're they
don't have access to University
Lifestyles so they can listen to a
podcast and then join a conversation and
bring up a question or an idea in the
discussion so that's why we that's why
we did it that's why I started to do it
and I still think it's a good it's a
good outlet and medium I mean you're so
lucky you get this kind of feedback like
probably because of what I do 90 of the
emails I get are things to the
equivalents of like Ben Shapiro is going
to shove his balls in your mouth and
you're gonna [ __ ] jump on them you
piece of [ __ ] like that's like my 90 of
like my daily correspondence and I'm
just like thank you very much Dr Matthew
McManus right do you remember wait you
teach at the University Matt you mean
your students email you and say Ben Ben
shapirs no they're actually a lot
they're actually a lot Ruder I should
say oh no he's still writing all those
anti-conservative pieces online though
it's true yeah I mean uh yeah I have
anyone that's coming out about millermen
and then I'm writing my big book on
consultism I do enjoy science Matthews
exactly I did get into a fight with
millerman and somebody else and Johannes
niederhausen or niederhosen or what I
call them I heard about that and it was
because he was trying to um have
undergraduate students who didn't read a
lot of texts to drop out so they could
join so they could uh pay for twelve
hundred dollars to take his courses and
I told I call them a softest on you know
on Twitter and he just like lost his
mind and was just like messaging me
Non-Stop and saying look how much you
published you haven't published a book
so you're not an academic okay dude yeah
but he's right about one thing
undergraduates do not read well yes yeah
it's true they do at the University of
Michigan they do yeah except for math
students of course Matthew have you have
you have you been in any public like big
debates uh yeah probably the biggest one
last year was I had a debate with the
head of the UK Iran Institute and we had
a deliberation on whether or not
objectivism or Democratic socialism
should be the way of the future oh my
God yeah I mean I I went in uh I was in
a good mid that day and it was also the
middle of the summer and I was going on
a camping trip so it was more of a kind
of friendly spat than uh a big debate
let's put it that way oh my God I'm
pretty much like banned from debates in
Latin America for now like nobody will
take me nobody will answer that was such
a fire debate yeah I remember I watched
yeah Matt you got to see uh Diego's
debate uh it was really fascinating in
Spanish Diego now you can take over the
anglophone world it's like a great it's
like this this this like weird I guess
like motivational like pyramid scheme
type like motivational bro in like
Mexico and and like Diego was just like
here's why like all the [ __ ] you're
saying is vacuous I mean I don't
normally endorse committing war crimes
against people but those people deserve
it you know and I've been offer like
pretty big like names like the the
presidential candidate for Argentina
Javier milay I don't know if you guys
have heard of him he's part of the atlas
Foundation as well like he's into the
Kato Institute and this all these like
[ __ ] libertarian thing tanks
CIA France yeah yeah the Heartland the
Koch brothers Koch brothers Brothers
well the Koch brothers slaves to be
honest because let's be honest they
don't have brothers they only deal with
other capitalists but but it's weird
like this like this debate uh world is
is interesting to me it's kind of
fascinating that um
in the end I don't know if you there's a
German political uh uh PhD in politics
um that wrote a theory about the spiral
of Silence I don't know if you guys have
heard about this is how how minorities
Drive uh the main narratives in social
media and how in the end uh out of pure
peer pressure people tend to be either
silent about their point of view or
agreed with the vocal minorities
that would never happen in an online
space
no no that's very interesting though I
mean congratulations uh a Shad that
you're not able to do that anymore but
uh it sounds like a useful thing pushing
down some of those new age capitalist
types if anything that's one of the
great Crusades of our time yeah wait so
what were we talking about again here
was there something about like the value
of philosophy and how do we deal with
kind of like doing philosophy when we
feel like we're we have no kind of like
ability to make change is that right am
I I think it was I did have thoughts
about that but I think we were
responding to the comments the comments
were mostly like something that I think
we did forget a lot which is like people
listen to us for a reason it doesn't
mean we're always right doesn't mean
we're always funny but you know in the
end it's a net good in the world even if
we don't see even if you know Biden gets
elected again it doesn't like that's not
the thing that we're doing yeah we
started this as like a creative outlet
but in the end it's also about creating
a space for critique and a little bit of
distance from what's going on because
we're so immersed in the world and the
spectacle and the well I was just gonna
say that I think philosophy is
intrinsically enjoyable and worth doing
regardless of the change and I'm sure I
feel like on this maybe Chris uh will
will agree with me the most uh being the
one who's maybe least interested in
political questions in his philosophy
because I think there's just a beauty
and a kind of satisfaction and a way of
understanding the world and yourself
that I think you know uh is is is I
think intrinsically uh experientially
valuable well if you think Chris isn't
interested in political questions all
you have to do is just bring up the
Turks know thyself well to be okay to be
fair Armenia is in a huge crisis right
now with Azerbaijan and oh you know we
have no backing from anybody and
Azerbaijan is backed by turkey
um we've lied about our population for
the last 10 years because of invasion
and artsoc which was um given away to
Azerbaijan you know by Stalin so it's a
really and now they've actually creeped
up into creeped up to the border of
Armenia so by the way I'm not anti-turk
I'm anti
um erdogan's government and his and his
denial of the Armenian Genocide and his
and obviously his occupation of Northern
Cyprus and of course uh you know the
kind of brutality and the the money that
that erdogan sends to ilyev who who's a
dictator who's openly stated he wants to
wipe Armenians off the face of the map I
just wanted to say that just you know my
personal view is that most philosophers
are encountered tend to fall into one of
two paradigms uh there are more
intellectually inclined philosophers who
tend to be interested in theory because
they enjoy conceptual puzzles uh and
they find a kind of pathological Joy uh
in resolving what seems like an
intrinsically difficult puzzle uh most
of the people who go into analytic
philosophy I think are predisposed this
way the other people I notice who tend
to become philosophers usually see it as
something that's a little bit closer to
a platonic calling let's call it that or
they associate some kind of religious
significance to the Quest for a capital
T truth or capital I Insight whatever it
is that you want to connote it and they
tend to usually survive more romantic uh
or even religious Tendencies to this
um I'm kind of reminded of what Freud
said where I pointed out that a lot of
people have this kind of oceanic feeling
uh when they confront reality and
in terms of which Paradigm I fall into
would probably be the second one rather
than the first one which isn't to say I
don't have a lot of respect for people
who do appreciate a good conceptual
puzzle and I do also right but I think
that also links to my own political
convictions since I never was interested
in political Theory just for the sake of
trying to theorize on what a just
society would look like for its own sake
as an abstract manner it really was a
matter of
trying to achieve a certain level of
justice for the world uh as a
Act of Grace if you want to call it that
so that's my kind of approach with this
I I relate a lot to what you said Matt
in a sense that um I mean I didn't get
into Philosophy by by you know by
Pleasure or by Indulgence at all I mean
it was very pragmatic like it was
because of my son's disease I felt a
deep discomfort with the way Society
works and the way Society is organized
and I felt he didn't have a place in the
world and I started looking for a place
and looking for uh you know people that
will help me understand what I was going
through and the fact that he couldn't
speak made me louder about my my ideas
and and got me into reading about uh
Injustice and you know I I eventually
got into Marx but also into different
readings about capacism you know this
notion of judging people by their
capacity to produce and the conundrum
that this creates you know like the the
the outcasts the others the ones that
don't fit the sub-altern
um the ones that are left over and my
approach to
to philosophy was never this like this
notion of being a friend to truth I I
much rather be a sophist and be
pragmatical about what I want to change
in the world than than just being in
love with the knowledge as a good in
itself you know like and and even in
even relating to these um critique of of
the of the of the platonic use of
sophism in the sense that you know that
artists were banned from the Republic in
the sense because artists do they were
the pure simulacrum uh they were not
like the philosophies are the
philosophers are the ones that are truly
in love with with the with knowledge and
Truth the sophists are the fake ones but
the artists they were like in a category
of themselves and and in that sense I
think um we should we should also
reflect back on the pragmatical use of
uh thinking and the pragmatical use of
criticism Beyond uh as an end in itself
even even if I understand even if I if I
admire and and I I even Aspire in some
way to the way people treat knowledge as
a as a standalone goal I think uh in the
way it does have to impact our reality
and the well-being because as I'm always
reminded of this sentence I think it's
one from Walter Benjamin that the
revolution is always late for someone
yeah I mean I'll give an example
um
bills will probably relate to this
because he's not a huge fan of
analytical philosophy but I took a class
in the philosophy of language with a guy
called Henry Jackman uh who's a great
teacher by the way so this doesn't
reflect on him but one of the papers we
read uh concerned the problem of
reference reference and um
representation and the philosophical
puzzle was say there was a guy driving
along in a car uh and he points in the
field and says that's a black cow right
there uh what would happen if it turned
out that there was just a cutout of a
black cow is he making it an error in a
statement especially and there's a
further wrinkle to this is which is what
if behind the image of the black Castle
there is a real it is a black cow and
the idea is well he made a statement
that is factually true but in terms of
the exact thing that he was pointing to
he wasn't actually referring to the
right object and I just remember sitting
there thinking to myself like this is a
very interesting conceptual puzzle but I
just don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] at all
right nobody gotta go
when you say I hate analytic philosophy
the philosophy of language I'm a little
bit all right with some of it but this
was the exact paper that I read except
the example was if you walk by a
classroom and you see a hologram of a
teacher teaching and you erroneously
form a Justified true belief that there
is a teacher teaching in there yet he is
actually at the back of the room where
you cannot see but you form a belief
based on the Hologram that you're
looking at do you have a Justified true
belief that there is a teacher in the
classroom so stupid
believe that having the right cognition
of states of Affairs is a true Earth
epistemology and then the Alternatives
but that's not a hearing or there I mean
the kind of point I was getting at with
this story which I'm glad pill is
related to is just that that kind of
philosophy just never appealed to me but
don't you think that there that there
should be an equal balance between the
theoretical and the Practical that it
shouldn't just be
a bound like a grounded by the Practical
there should be some like I agree with
what Victor said Victor said something
you know there is this you know when
Aristotle says that philosophy begins in
wonder you know that Wonder in the
theoretical can lead us to practical
questions about the world right there is
this kind of interior and exterior
element
um of our experience we could talk about
the bodily we can talk about the
practical but we there's also the kind
of
in our last episode as much but but like
rorty and Donald Davidson are incredibly
close like Donald Davidson and Roy
there's a the conversation they have on
YouTube for instance like that we we
just don't need a theory of meaning
anymore because the theory of meaning
implies a theory of Truth and what we're
moving towards is is pragmatic action
and I think it's moving more towards the
balance that Chris was talking about
like analytic philosophy is coming to
terms with its own history of of you
know Russell and logicism and and the
linguistic turn and now it's coming back
around and and I'm sympathetic to it in
so far as it's actually like grasping
its own Journey from Fraga now to
actually thinking about questions that
have a wider application than just
conceptual puzzles like Matt was talking
about right yeah I'll give an example
Chris that kind of gets it what I'm
talking about within Theory because I
agree with you it's not like we should
just believe in anything because it
happens to conform to our
preconceptions right that'd be sophism
take a singular person like wittenstein
right the early wickenstein with the
track that is logical philosophagus
created extraordinary intellectual
apparatus uh that is kind of isolate
true uh and this really quite gorgeous
uh almost Sublime way and you could
associate it with all kinds of platonic
connotations uh but even he was aware of
the fact that
as true or as benign or sorry as um
Sublime as this might be it said very
little to a lot of his more important
and pressing questions like how it was
he was supposed to live his life what
was beautiful what it meant to be good
and this is one of the reasons I've
always admired his second phase more
than his first one precisely because he
Retreats from this kind of icy platonic
Heaven down into the streets to try to
listen to what people are saying and the
kind of words that they use to bring
meaning to their life that's the kind of
philosophy that's always intrigued me
more uh than the kind of thing you'd
find in attracted us this is that's a
really good point because what does who
does Wittgenstein end with but can't
right in uncertainty so I don't know I
only care that the question of why
philosophy is answered if your answer is
just I like Puzzles I don't care that's
fine if your answer is just I want a job
and I want to make money talking to
undergraduates good for you I don't care
as long as you have an answer and anyway
I'm gonna move on we can keep uh we can
refer back to this if you want but I got
two more together two comments they are
about a propaganda and nostalgia a
recent theme has been propaganda
myth and the effectiveness of say a q9
conspiracy theories and lamenting that
the left doesn't have something similar
my question is how would the left create
something similar and equally effective
when it seems like the requirement for
that Effectiveness is through propaganda
causing you know the doubt the confusion
Etc or the left is same is always too as
clearly as possible describe Capital
capitalism and to authentically want to
relieve the suffering of people rather
than to just further confuse them so
that they can be manipulated it just
doesn't seem like
there's the same means in the same ends
that are sought so I'm wondering if that
comparison of
another
Q Anon or something comparable to Q Anon
is even a comparison could be made or if
we're looking at something just entirely
different and what is that entirely
different mobilizing myth
conspiracy theory or whatever you want
to call it
that was from our friend age of bum
fires thank you very much and here's the
other one it's a little shorter
something I wanted to talk about is the
use of nostalgia as a tool for
propaganda given your recent episode on
Bernays essentially media is a means for
removing people's ability to
conceptualize novel Futures I know
Fisher talked about the cancellation of
the future but I just feel like things
have gotten worse and evolved likely
with worsening material conditions since
he wrote and gave that lecture do you
have any thoughts on this thanks
congratulations on 100. that was from
Burke who has a very nice voice he
should be podcasting with that yeah
he's doing ASMR here at least yeah
yeah okay so we got propaganda as the
first question how does leftist
propaganda if we want to call it that
should it compete is it doing the same
thing as propaganda or not and then the
second question is if we don't have a
future
then why and is our future becoming more
and more opaque uh given I guess our
media environment and that Q Anon is
thrown in there so I just wanted to know
your guys's thoughts on that my take on
these two comments is is very one very
close to each other is the left trying
to to to battle capitalism with an
idealistic approach you know it's like
oh my god really like the there's
nothing worse than an idealistic left
you have to be materialistic like this
this is why it's so hard for me to
understand people trying to reinvent
their left from me idealism it's like
guys like you're gonna fall right into
the Trap of capitalism once again like
it makes no sense of course we have it
much harder because we're trying to win
a battle against a 300 billion dollar
propaganda industry with memes and books
that nobody reads it's like of course
it's impossible in the sense that that's
that's why that's that's why falling
back into this notion that um it's a
radical reading of Spinoza uh the world
is material everything else is just
symptomatic
um emerging out of this material
conditions so trying to change it from
idealism makes no sense what we have to
change is material conditions and
material relations not idealistic uh
narratives of what is happening and
inspiring people what is it what are
they criticizing a lack of left theology
it makes no sense of of what about what
about the idea that you do have to like
if you want to build a movement there
needs to be a set of narratives at the
base of that movement right and those
are going to convey ideas are going to
understand the word world through
Concepts and you have the take like if
you're a materialist take of of like our
our ideas are really just getting back
to a material kind of under undertow
that we're all being tugged Along by but
what about like how do you construct
even just like say a rhetorical
foundation for a movement let's say yeah
I was just gonna say for me you know I I
agree with what you're saying Diego
um but there is a sense that a strong
kind of materialism which then would
lead to a kind of Telos and reductive
materialism would not be a good thing
like there's there is a reason why you
know you know the Industrial Revolution
and a a more more kind of humanist
materialism led to some of the problems
that we have with climate change not
that I'm saying that we shouldn't be
focusing on the material element
especially when it comes to political
action but I do agree with what Eric was
saying
um that we do need some kind of concept
some conceptual schema
right so and that we can like look at
look at bad you for example he's a great
example of the subjectivization or the
Fidelity to an event or some kind of
concept that allows the people to band
together within the material so maybe
like an idealist realist or an ideal
material but I understand your your
skepticisms with idealism
because of bid you sorry no no go ahead
I would much rather do any version of
The Mechanical Turk from playing chess
from Benjamin and just say that it's the
other way around I think um even if like
the Mechanical Turk is the sense of
leftist theology or what whatever meta
narrative we're going to create to make
people rally behind it but beyond Behind
the table or like below the table is
dialectical materialism yeah I'd say
that from an intellectual standpoint I
agree with you Diego uh and I think that
it's extremely problematic if we try to
Aid conspiracy theorizing because I
think conspiracy theorizing is
inevitably idealist uh in the sense that
it's a totalizing narrative and it's
almost always personalized as well uh
rather than a structural critique you
have one set of people uh that's almost
always responsible for all the problems
that govern us right which also lets us
off the hook because we don't have to
deal with the fact that many of the
institutions from which we are alienated
are governing us but they're not
controlled necessarily by anyone
exactly independent of us the one
problem I have with this is that
intellectually I think that's all fine
uh it's just that the reality is that
from my perspective by far the most
powerful uh mobilizing leftist mythology
uh was ultimately an unconvincing one
but there's no denying its success uh
which one the more eschatological
approaches to Marxism that you saw in
the early 20th century right this idea
that vulgar marks this kind of idea that
everything is about class struggle the
victory of the working class is
inevitable and once capitalism Falls
yeah exactly because it's in hair
contradictions we're going to be
triumphant I mean this was so successful
that you even had conservative
commentators like Joseph schupender
think that Marx is exactly right
capitalism is going to end we're
completely doomed and it's gonna be a
horrible thing right now I don't want to
return to that intellectually but
there's no denying its kind of power as
a mobilizing force because if you think
that Victory is assured then you're far
more likely to sign up uh from Marxist
parties so what I do think we need to do
now is work on constructing more
meaningful kinds of leftist narratives
that aren't necessarily theological in
the idealist sense but capture some of
the sacral quality of theology for
materials purposes and I think there are
two authors that are doing a fantastic
job of that right now uh one is gizek
right uh with this kind of materialist
reinterpretation of Christianity as an
emanator in a Gallatin I agree the other
person is uh Martin hagland in his book
this life uh where he actually argues
that a kind of atheism uh centered
around uh Democratic socialism might
actually be more meaningful than a
conventional religious life uh because
there's a kind of finiteness to human
existence which makes every choice you
make significant now I'm not saying
either of these two things are the
answer uh but they're experiments and
again trying to capture some of that
sacral quality for materialism and I'm
looking forward to seeing more of that
in the future no I don't do don't we
think that we're we're kind of picking
on idealism here like kind of making it
into a straw I mean all the Q anons yeah
I'm not a Hague alien but I'm thinking
that you know in a sense that you know
the Q Anon stuff a lot of the the
rhetoric the propaganda that that's
coming from the right
um is actually not um it's not an
idealism I like think about this for a
second like when when I when I see you
know West Coast Russians arguing against
left the left the thing that they're
they're wanting is natural right like
they don't they they hate this idea of
Human Rights and freedom from the
enlightenment they're they're hoping for
a
um the natural right of this classical
movement that you get from Schmidt and
and Strauss so well there's some kind of
idealism to that though uh and again I
don't think Terry Eagleton is right that
wherever you see idealism you see
reaction right but definitely idealism
is more potent on the political right
than it is on the political left
sometimes even in unexpected places uh
so take somebody like Martin Heidegger
right uh Martin Heidegger is definitely
not a conventional idealist right uh
he's very much focused on the
interactions of the body with the world
but what differentiates his theory of
History big picture theory of history
from something like Marx's is precisely
this idea that ideas are what Drive
history forward the kind of metaphysical
Frameworks in which we operate and in
this sense he sees all of history as a
descent from the original moment where
people were genuinely doing great
philosophy especially great people down
to this kind of mass culture where
people aren't doing this anymore because
we come to egalitarian too Democratic to
focus on the world of the day that's a
kind of idealist narrative right uh and
I think it's the kind of thing that we
should avoid if at all possible so I
don't think idealism has to be
reactionary but I have to say that I
disagree because part of that first
question was directed at me why are you
talking about myth why are you talking
about propaganda and really
if you want to call it class struggle
you could call it class struggle
something like that is ultimately a
numbers game and even if you have the
best theory
that has ever been invented maybe
someone's doing that right now they're
coming up with the best theory the best
you can do with the best theory is like
five percent of people because it's
boring tedious and most people aren't
interested in it I mean present company
excluded but if you have a good story
and it can be a really dumb story like
an alien zombie was raised from the dead
by his alien dad or a meme and you have
two billion people that believe in that
[ __ ] yeah exactly I would say just for
the numbers argument to load you can
have whatever Theory but if you're not
persuasive meaning you don't have like
an immediate buy-in for people who
aren't going to listen to your argument
they just want to know okay I'm involved
in this I would say that early early
20th century Marxism is a lot more
successful than yeah early 21st century
right right on the money bills I think
like 99 of the comments I have to
address online is that the fact that I'm
a communist and I have an iPhone
yeah I mean I also just want to say this
is purely anecdotal but you're
absolutely [ __ ] right I mean I've met
senior Marxist professors uh who usually
when they're drunk but not always will
admit to me usually with these tones of
like religious concern that they've
never actually read dos Capital like I
had a senior Marxist who was like I've
only ever read volume one and I've
written so much about volume two I
couldn't I've never actually read the
thing and I was like don't worry man
nobody actually [ __ ] reads those
books like you know well I wanted it
good yeah I wanted to come up with
something a little bit more concrete
um and it's comes I've been listening to
this audiobook and my bicycling around
Toronto uh by this political scientist I
forget her name but it's called like how
um uh Civil Wars start it's a really
interesting new book that goes over like
a lot of the the kind of empirical
evidence on and one of the points she
makes which kind of like I think links
back to this like why can't the left
have a kind of propaganda and it's like
a very simplistic kind of answer but it
made sense to me
um which is that and this this is kind
of like verified over and over again in
in psychological research so like human
beings have an intense
um loss aversion so like if you can get
a human being to perceive that they're
going to lose something or they're about
to lose something that is much more
strongly perceived than the idea that
you're going to gain something so this
is why the right is always going to have
an advantage because the right is always
going to be good at talking about all
the things you're losing right they're
always going to bring that and the left
is always going to have a disadvantage
because a lot of our fight is like what
are you going to gain from having this
and human beings just cognitively for
whatever reason are really bad at
perceiving or experiencing the possible
gain but they are hyper hyper sensitive
to the perception of a loss it's like
you have more to lose than your chains
you also have the [ __ ] scraps so the
left so the right is always going to win
on that it's like we're always going to
have an uphill battle so in that sense
that cognitive bias so Victory leads it
straight into the argument in favor of
nostalgia like using Nostalgia as a
control mechanism for keeping everything
you know for keeping your memories
keeping your childhood keeping your
icons keeping your Brands keeping your
toys like this is this is The Narrative
of the perpetuation of the status quo
and of course what what dialectical
materialism talks about is change it's
inevitable change that is produced out
of the resolution of contradictions but
then again how do you build a narrative
on this idea that is either not well
received and it's also very
anti-idealistic in the sense like in my
reading is it should not be it should
not rely on on idealistic meta
narratives to sustain itself or even to
lead a movement like when it's hard is
to convince people to make sense out of
this from a material angle not from an
idealistic angle because from the idea
idealistic angle we were going to lose
them very quickly well I think and I
think materially
um and this book which obviously about
why Civil War is erupt and one of the
things she kind of points out is like
when those Civil Wars are erupt and when
there is like revolutionary change it's
because people have a very very strong
perception that they're losing something
right and maybe that's why because yeah
and same with what happened right in in
Russia like the October Revolution right
like these are things where there's like
a loss that is being perceived and there
is like a panic to get to prevent that
loss and then possibly have something
different take its place no no
Revolution no revolution has ever been
started by oh you're gonna gain all
these things all these great things are
gonna happen that's never happened in
terms of this research at least yeah but
you know there has to be I'm going to
bring this back to mythology there has
to be a level of balance you know
Nietzsche says it best if there's two
apple if there's too much apollonium
there's too much structure there's too
much rigidity right then you know we're
stuck we're stuck with the Veil of Maya
and then we need Dionysus to come in
with drink and hand to just smash this
this structure but you know there there
is a level of there is something that we
can learn from mythology it's not the
nostalgic way there is this level of
there is some kind of unconscious
content and form that's passed on
um there is this idea you know there's
struggle their Strife tragedy that we
can learn from
um I'm speaking in this sense you know
known as a shelingian but you know there
is there are positives to mythology
um oh yeah I mean I'm going to see
Bernie Sanders this weekend right and
when he says things like
we need to get the billionaire class uh
out of our politics uh and we need to
make money work for people uh the
intellectual side of me is like well you
know billionaires aren't really
responsible to this they're under the
systematic law of coercion just like
Mark says
but you know I'm also a practical enough
guy to say that that's a helpful
rhetoric uh at least in the United
States because it's something that
resonates with people so I'm not going
to sit there and be doing that dweebie
thing online being like Bernie Sanders
is wrong to say that billionaires are
the ones oppressing us actually what we
need is materialist analysis right
just call it a call it a god oppressing
you yeah yeah it's it's weird to me
because you know like in the in the
structuralist movement starting with
Levy Strauss right politics is the new
mythology right you can even see this in
in barths right like like his
mythologies like politics operates on
that level of of Mythology creating
creating a kind of narrative
that you buy into and then and then
using kind of iconography and and and
memes and things you can grab onto and
it's it's always strange though the way
we talk like that's idealism in a
certain sense the way we talk about it
but idealism in in its original sense
too is like a metaphysical Doctrine we
talk about it we talk about it like it's
an epistemological position like
correctness depends on what we think
whereas the idealism in its more
metaphysical sense is like that what is
real is composed of psychic like like
what is real is of the nature of mind
and that's the that's the idealism I I
kind of prefer I don't prefer the
idealism of Mythology and narrative and
and that sort of thing because it's it's
in that that is more of an
epistemological position where it's like
it it focuses on intentionality
and our interior life determining the
outside world
right you have this whole idea of
representationalism like I think Rory
gives this example it's like
does what you call atoms conform to the
meaning of the word Adam or does the
meaning of the word Adam conform to what
atoms really are there's platonism yeah
and when you're in that struggle you
just choose one side you're the idealist
or you're the realist my word Adam is
the way it is because of what atoms are
or atoms are because of what we call
them or what we mean by the word Adam
it's it's an irreconcilable opposition
and we just have to leave that behind
because in the end it's just it's just
representation of it's epistemology it's
just the basis of well for them it's
it's a kind of scientism it's the basis
of how we build and use knowledge
but when you move to a more Praxis based
politics you just have to leave that
though that and those labels behind
idealism realism materialism like in a
way they're holding us back when they
have those meanings of
like what's right and what's wrong
what's material what's ideal you know
those are those are those labels
if I may I have one last uh Patron
message and it's about work so it's kind
of to do with this um why why does not
Revolution happen and he's speaking
specifically about uh you know people
with
what we used to call the middle class or
like a white collar job why don't they
want to revolt and I think it's a little
bit telling and we can involve it and
it's our last one so we could just go to
the end here
hey my name's rubell and I'm a teacher
from England I wanted to ask you guys
about the subject to work and ordinary
people's relations with their bosses
quote unquote leaders
um why do you think people are reluctant
to blame their bosses especially in
white collared jobs where a degree is
usually necessary particularly if the
same bosses individuals are responsible
for implementing policy that benefits
the system at the cost of their workers
I think this speaks the reason it
brought it to mind is exactly what
Victor said if you if you got 100K a
year
your job is still probably exploited
labor by definition but you have enough
[ __ ] to go home to
the revolution's not really going to be
worth it yeah I think that's the same
Revolution and Revolution also crucially
risks losing what you exactly so are you
gonna roll the dice if you've got a
Skidoo and uh a nice Audi yeah which is
also another reason why people like in
that book she also notices how like in a
lot of really like developing countries
poor countries even though a lot of
people are living in really bad
conditions as long as they don't have a
perception that they're going to lose
even more or lose status they're
actually like fine with their position
right like so it's really hard to get
them to mobilize uh if they're used to
their situation
um unless you can show that they are
about to lose something or that there's
like a risk that they're going to lose
even more of their status and you see
this happening and you know in a lot of
African countries those conflicts
between between the Tutsis and the the
Hutu and the the Tutsis or whatever I
think in in Rwanda because like even
though pre-tron transition to democracy
they were in poor situation but like
when they saw that they're going to lose
their status then like that's like a a
flash point for revolution even though
overall their situation was already
really bad there's another problem also
and there's been some research in
political psychology on this that speaks
actually to Victor's point but in a
slightly different way uh which is a
number of researchers have tried to
figure out why it is that more people
aren't motivated by concerns for
this is called extraordinary inequality
particularly class inequality but you
can apply this in a lot of different
circumstances so why is it that the
working class doesn't resent the
billionaire class for example uh and you
have some neoliberal economists who've
tried to insist uh people don't care
about things like inequality uh you know
they should only care about how well
they're doing relative to how they were
doing you know a couple months ago and
obviously that's not true but it turns
out that the Empirical research right
now also doesn't vindicate the kind of
marxist narrative uh that people are
going to be concerned with say the
billionaire class because the kinds of
inequalities that people care about are
usually far more local right so a
janitor will carry an awful lot more
about whether or not a plumber is
getting paid more than them uh then they
will whether the guy who owns the
plumbing company is making more than
them right uh you know a teacher at a
university who's an adjunct will care a
lot more about what the tenured faculty
around him are making uh than he will
with the neoliberalization of Education
now that's not to say that people can't
become cognizant of those deeper
inequalities if they are motivated
politically the right way it's just a
lot harder to get people to
instinctively think that way because
it's not something that's apparent to
them immediately right I think if we can
interpret going against the bosses as
unionizing or going on strike
and then and then you frame that
situation in I mean like we've been on
strike before and what we get is like oh
you're being selfish you want more pay
you want higher pay you're sacrificing
the greater good for your like local
good right so we're in this situation of
well it's the economy versus like what
you want it's the greater good versus
your local struggle and that's how we
and that's how we frame those types of
situations and I think we were talking
about this on another episode too it
kind of it can kind of translate as well
to like blockadia and local resistance
right like you're gonna stand there and
block
like developers from coming in to cut
down this forest and the media or
whatever like anyone who's Pro
development is going to say well these
people are just trying to
forward their own personal local good
over like what's good for the general
economy and so if going against the
bosses the bosses are always thinking
about the economy and what's good and
let's let's ignore that they're profit
driven Enterprises for the for the
moment like if you're going to unionize
you have to change the narrative in that
sense right it's not it's not the local
good in your personal pay versus
you know like the global economy it's
it's it it is a kind of in that point
it's it it's a kind of dignity and
respect of like like your struggle is
the global struggle and what the bosses
want they want you know they want
personal wealth they want profit and
they'll stay there for the the economy
and and just framing it in that way is
extremely problematic and I think so
going against the bosses if it's
unionizing or striking like what we're
seeing right now with Starbucks it's an
Amazon warehouses right like that that
is something that should be should be
mimicked elsewhere because that's going
to create you know the conditions for
people to have better material existence
as opposed to this sort of General
notion of of well if you go on strike
you're going to Halt the economy and
it's gonna it's gonna disempower people
on a on a more General basis like that's
[ __ ] I think you should frame it in
in such a way that your struggle is
everybody's struggle and I guess that's
kind of kind of a universalism in the in
finding that universalism in the in the
local struggles rather than
going to that immediately thinking about
the global economy I don't know if I
said that very eloquently but that's
I gave it a shot saying we need to
reframe yeah yeah and then how do you
change the narrative change that [ __ ]
narrative exactly but but but for me the
problem here arises in this in that
there's nothing that escapes the logic
of capital correctly like I think even
these janitors and even these teachers
they don't they don't know that they're
thinking within the logic of capital
they're almost like trapped into this
and that's why I really love the job
example from the Bible it's like they
you know the the way the guy uh framed
the sentence and he framed the problem
it's almost like he's saying like I wish
I could be a better worker if only I was
paid a little bit more you know like
like his his logic is completely trapped
by Capital like is you could say from a
very traditional Marxist analogy he
doesn't have class Consciousness he
probably doesn't will class
Consciousness change his perspective of
the world I doubt it right now like I
really doubt it like I I don't think I
don't think it it's it's enough anymore
for for for people to actually Sue and
drive real change but what I do think is
that his logic of the the reason of the
world and the functioning of the world
is the logic of capital
like what he's just asking for more
breadcrumbs he he know he just wants a
little bit more maybe if we unionize we
get some more healthy delicious
breadcrumbs and maybe we get four
instead of three breadcrumbs and then we
will be happy and and again it's hard to
convince people to to to create change
in Risk what they have risk losing what
they have to gain something that is
uncertain if if they're not hungry if
they're not truly hungry and I'm not
talking about metaphysical hunger I'm
talking about real hunger that the
hunger that actually drives Revolution
historically we we are in a in a crisis
of overproduction not of scarcity this
is unprecedented I think past
revolutionary models are in a way
insufficient because they they dwell in
scarcity and right now we are in in a
problem of over abundance we are over
stimulated we have excess of dopamine we
have excessive consumption we have
excess of goods we have excessive
possibilities we have excess of
entertainment I think I think
revolutionary politics have to take into
account that that the context the
material context is different from the
past in that that's why I like the zizik
reading of uh re-reading lending it's
not really reading learning in redoing
what Lenin did is re-reading learning in
learning from his failures but also
understanding that the moment we are
right now is a new moment is is not a
moment that we can look back into
history and replicate past revolutionary
tactics and apply them today that's
that's my that's my that's my reading of
of this uh this cry for help because
it's true I think a lot of people and
this is something I was having
conversation with pills the other the
other day I think the one topic we need
to to talk uh with these people it's
about the issue of property because
we're we're coming to a point in life
where the the main concern that is going
to change the way people live and the
relationship of power is that people are
gonna own nothing and and I think the
relationship to property and ownership
is going to be the determining force or
power
variable to determine the future of how
material conditions will produce ideal
Electric superstructures in the next
Generations
this from the guy with the iPhone am I
right yeah yeah well I mean you know if
anything I feel like maybe I mean I hate
to say it but it almost sounds like an
argument for accelerationism I mean not
exactly what Diego was saying but just
in general like in terms of
I was thinking about that when you were
saying you know you need to feel the
real hunger right and it's like you know
how are you going to get that to happen
unless [ __ ] gets way worse you don't
like like my argument is more like um
again
is is not us by intention producing
change in the world is the world acting
that produces the intention of changing
us you know like I I think we got it the
other way around I think like like I'm
much more inclined to this notion of
pills explaining capitalism as a God in
the sense that it's a system with his
own internal logic acting upon the world
and we're just one more variable we're
we're capitalumano we're just like one
more variable in the system we're acting
out the will of of a system that is that
is beyond us
yeah it sounds like it could be a
shelling argument if you materialize
Freedom a little bit it's not far off or
by wrong Chris yeah where's no no I
think the visible remainder there I do
remember at one point guard said that
the Book of Job is the most problematic
part of the Bible and Carl Ewing agreed
with them and I was like yeah I mean it
is a story where Satan comes and like
God you don't have the ball so let me
torture this guy God's like oh yeah go
away uh and then he talked to this guy I
did nothing wrong uh comes back and he's
like blisters yeah you didn't [ __ ] him
hard enough let me [ __ ] him even harder
he does then job finally complains he's
like this is really unfair and God's
response to them is who the [ __ ] do you
think you're talking to I'm the biggest
meanest toughest [ __ ] deity [ __ ] that
you know and you don't have any right to
[ __ ] about it and that's the end of the
story well there's an exegetical point
that the Book of Job is actually older
than the entire rest of the Bible except
for the first six chapters of Genesis
it's like a scripture from another time
makes so much sense because that's the
the zero level necessity uh for for the
structure of theology like you have to
believe Beyond any positive
reinforcement above all sufferings and
durable you have to believe like that's
the ground zero for a theory to work
first you have to believe the end of the
theory will make sense
we could keep going but why don't we not
keep going it's been yeah we've already
gone we've already exceeded Diego's hard
limit
but but this is too good this is too
good I won't I will not miss it and by
the way the Joe Points I can see on
Wikipedia uh Scholars agree it was
probably written between the seventh and
4th Century BC fact check you didn't
know I was gonna pull that Bible
knowledge out of my ass did you I just
wanted to verify trust but verify just
like the Russians say I was going to ask
all of you what you all think of
um the protests with the without art
galleries recently
um with the per the girl the Pearl
Earring and
um Van Gogh's flowers
um what does everyone think about
how these people are reacting because I
think it's badass because anything is
better than nothing
uh I think it's I think it's if it's
strategically flawed I think it's it's
it's gonna create a backlash I don't
really think it's getting the intended
effect of getting people to be like oh
wow I didn't know about materialism
until you destroyed a painting like
they're throwing potatoes at the
paintings they're not but there's like
bearing tomato soup of things wasn't
there someone who put Painting or who
put paint on the like like painting I
don't know here's the other tomato soup
at a van Gogh I think oh yeah their
point is that art is protected and
nature and nature is not my point is
okay why not why not move from the ark
and go attack Banks then if you want to
talk about something that's protected
currency and money and capital is
protected there's no money in banks
anyway it's I think from measurements
are coming to life memes are coming to
life and this is a scary time to be
alive no I think I think from a
benjaminian perspective they're
attacking the aura right they're looking
at the Mona Lisa they're throwing soup
on it it's like the erratic mode of
perception where there's
authenticity originality there's only
one of something
they're attacking a kind of scarcity
but it's it's a it's a new mode of
production and technological it's from
Benny means essay on the technological
reproducibility of the work of art but
also they're right we only have one
world
I mean I tend to agree with you though I
think it's strategically flawed because
I don't think that these efforts to
de-sacralize or desupplement works of
art is really the way to go politically
forward I think it's a lot more
important to try to de-sacralize or
desublimate idealize forms of life or
verified forms of life particularly
things like the nation the state and
other things like that and I'm not
really sure what Banco has to do with
all that I'm going to be much tougher
I'm gonna say like [ __ ] them like what
is this dumb idea about stopping like
carbon and stopping like fossil fuel
like this is this is ridiculous I mean I
live in Latin America if if we go green
we go broke like that's so dumb like
it's it's it's incredible that people
can can make such a childish analysis
and just say like we have to stop uh
like fossil fuels right now otherwise
we're destroying the Earth it's like
yeah bro but like do you know how
expensive food will be in the rest of
the world if we stop like fossil fuel
right now it doesn't make any sense
that's why it's childish like even
beyond the ACT whether but they're
whether acting uh from and like but
they're responding against for me is
like a
it's like a very privileged point of
view about about the world that's why I
say like it's just memes coming to life
it makes no sense there's no dapping
into the into the protest I know I mean
there was we used to joke about that
when I was living in Mexico so because a
lot of animals left wing supporters were
like you should get rid of pemex i'm
like [ __ ] like he needs paybacks right
yeah if we were to get rid of pamax hair
would all the corruption goes yeah we'll
starve are you guys crazy now we're
right back in the mythology element of
it again it's like okay if you recycle
are you really saving the environment
exactly no that's green washing
[ __ ] there's like 80 companies
doing this [ __ ] it's not our [ __ ]
fault all right you gotta stop this
producers who are banking on this [ __ ]
no no category today no category
absolutely none there was a recent study
from a friend of mine that is Economist
in Spain no category today consumes 100
of what they do what they produce
there's leftovers in everything that we
produce in life today everything oh yeah
every category is about waste I know I
mean the world throws out about a
trillion dollars worth of food waste
every single year uh which is
astonishing when you think that there
are 700 million hungry people in the
club and probably growing actually after
cope it uh I mean as you pointed out
very accurately we're not living in a
problem uh in a world by under
consumption or sorry or scarcity yeah
we're living in a world that's
characterized by mass affluence uh and
there's systemic reasons why people
aren't able to access it so and podcasts
too yeah way too many way way too way
too many minutes way too many people way
too many white people yeah exactly
overproduction of mental space I'm gonna
stop it let's stop it right now in fact
let's throw painting out of the wall at
the strip of the screen let's throw
painting on this podcast don't listen
we're just contributing to the problem
but thank you for getting us to 100
episodes everyone that was great
um and anyone any one of you if you want
to send me some links to put in the
description I know Diego's got a book if
you can uh read on espanol Chris new
article Matt I'm sure 10 new articles or
so and uh I have a new book that came
out a few weeks ago
thank you guys for coming anything else
you want to just drop on at the end here
one one final thing I've told you this
before but I would love to have you guys
on my channel like I would love to give
you the exposure even if I'm the only
non-philoser here I'm the truth sophist
I I can use my platform to give you guys
the the microphone and there's a couple
of million people that will love to
listen to you guys so anytime you want
to do it just let me know I'll organize
it I will have you on my channel will be
my pleasure for real as a group or
individually let me know you had me at
Millions actually I wouldn't mind doing
that
you have to speak Spanish though
I have plenty videos in Portuguese and
in English as well
what are your last word thanks for
having me on and this was interesting
um I'm not normally so immersed into
politics my my areas metaphysics and
ontology and more of the environmental
and
ecological and climate crisis so we post
a lot of art also I do I'm very I'm very
inspired by art so I was just listening
to a lot of your arguments and points
and
yeah and I'm not really good at I'm not
really good at the whole podcast
structure I'm I don't know sometimes I I
get like trapped in my own thoughts so I
think you're a fabulous contribution
yeah you did great yeah it's good to
have a an Eclectic mix because as that
listener said plus you know we're just
talking about pragmatism these days
it it was a bunch of five it was a bunch
of five materialists picking on an
idealist here so yeah there you go that
will make your uh your audience I just
said idealism I need a metaphysician
idealism is a conspiracy theory and we
need more of those that's what I said
well I love Lord of the Rings I can say
that much not the show no you don't I
love everything Lord of the Rings live
with the [ __ ] alone I love everything
Middle earth related what I feel about
Star Wars
he just pulled out swords
speaking of Star Wars Andor is I hate
Star Wars
but you know the enemy in Andor is
America yep and George Lucas said as
much and they're going into like the
bureaucracy and the banality of how this
whole evil empire functions and it is a
it's America and its colonies it's a
great amen we should have a conversation
about Dune uh portraying the war in
Afghanistan oh yes
spicy yeah all right thank you everyone
thank you listeners for getting us to
100 everyone who showed up here today uh
was great and thanks for the uh
inspiring inspiring conversation and
everyone who commented also sending us
those things it was fun yeah it was
great great to hear we could continue
that I love that yeah I like that a lot
we should do it again all right thank
you everybody and goodbye good night
good morning
[Music]
thank you